my nation is
being seeing this
video bro let me tell something let
me you know KFC finger look looking
looking no no no no boycot list boycot
list KFC yeah okay no problem
hfc eight months ago I downloaded
Audible and I was going through the
books there and they only had the s and
I was like why isn't anyone doing an
Islamic version of audible and finally
true IL has come up with an app brother
and sisters where it's an Islamic
version going through what Quran
scholarly gems da
woman and history and kids and check
this out check how this sounds him that
a man would set out from y or mud we
have got the Muslim audible brother and
sisters finally alhamdulillah to seek
true they've only got a limited amount
of space for the beta mode Brothers
sisters download it now and benefit from
it cuz let me tell you something it is
going to change the knowledge that I
seek throughout my life
inshallah brothers and sisters and dear
friends you would probably remember this
witch and many other people would want
to call her something else maybe change
the W there but anyways this woman if
you guys remember about a year ago when
the war happened this woman is the most
VI vial woman to be walking this Earth
she's I think the mayor of the city in
Israel something on those uh lines and
she was very blatant but her and her
group was basically planning they would
having binocular looking at the Gaza
Strip and saying this way we're going to
move we're going to have a nice beach
view we're going to like literally
fullblown Annihilation genes I talk full
blown casually comfortably no no uh uh
things at all now let's watch this and
let's see how Allah humiliated her with
her own mouth and what happened to the
idea so here's the videoan let's watch
what she's saying
I think that now I address directly to
president of the United States Biden
here from this small Israel to the big
United States of
America don't think that we will stop
the war in Gaza before be put a total
end to Hamas to the supporters of Hamas
and resettling the entire area of Gaza
by Jews okay Dan you that is clear you
hear it's a romantic thing the S want to
see it want to see the sea I want to see
the sea M men women children doesn't
matter
now let's watch how Allah humiliated
this little with my nation is
being
humiliated one more time have you seen
that PA she
goes we have been
humili you know when someone takes a
deep breath in a pause they're stopping
theel from crying bro that was the
beautiful Enemy by who by the our
leaders made our enemies humiliate us I
very much oppose the agreement with
Hamas now because Israel was in a
position that we had the upper hand and
now the Hamas has the upper hand and it
has influence on the future of Israel
and on the future of the Middle East and
to some extent on in many aspects it has
influence on the entire world because
Hamas being strong affects all the
country
of the world so now I hear Arabs from
all around Having the courage to speak
about against Israel and to speak about
the an annihilation of Israel of killing
me killing my my neighbors my family God
forbid but this is what they are talking
about they are exercising they are doing
the drills the training in order to kill
us and now they got the encouragement
the strength to do it because because of
the deal because of the deal or because
of 15 months of the war in Gaza no it's
because the deal is the cause for the
encouragement the the Hamas in Gaza and
he the J saying maybe it's because
there's been a mass she saying War but
it's not war at least she B at least
she's like okay you know she's no no she
goes they want to kill me no nobody
wants to kill you now you become a
victim what about all that big talk that
happened before giving it giving it
large saying yeah yeah yeah we're going
to wipe him no intended give me
a yeah we just want to see the view yeah
whoever supports yeah whoever's there we
got we we're going to end the job yeah
that's what we're going to do what are
you going to do yeah what are you going
to do you're just going to deplete your
pill Supply that's what you're going to
do BR talk I enjoy this so much I don't
know what is you know what I you know
what today I had orange juice that's a
lot of sugar yeah I a cant wow filled
with pistachio cream that's a lot of sug
then I had this donut thing with some
fruit on there that's again a lot
of no no no no
just just this morning I had all of the
sugar but you know what seeing this
video bro let me tell you something let
me you know KFC finger looking looking
no no no no boycot list boyot list KFC
yeah okay no problem uh hfc AFC all
FCS PFC pfcs all of them let me tell
something brother what phenomenal
phenomenal I I don't know what to say
but Allah mated her with her own mouth
this was so sweet so let I'm in like
this
Zen in in a form of ecstasy no that's
Haram not if you do it properly no
that's Haram about Zen is that I just
feel like you know when you go somewhere
the temperature is so perfect it's not
cold or hot you're not hungry or full
yeah you're just perfect that's in but
you just get I just I just watch this
it's just can you guys just Express
please how you feeling cuz right now
we're look for words like I just I just
feel so very satisfying completed I
think this this can be compiled into a
satisfying video some people see these
satisfying videos when things are
proportioned properly this
Che I need check my heart rate I think
my heart rate is even Dro like it's in
like nice there's nothing there I think
you're dead oh that's nice Dash Dash
Okay h
so guys what we want to say is Allah
subhana tala is the most just and Allah
says in the Quran never Allah is unaware
of what the evil doers do all your all
your prayers all your duas all your s
all your charity all your efforts they
have not gone wasted despite what you
think Allah's got his own timeline and
he fulfills and he follows his own
timeline not the timeline of you and me
that we want things done now he only
delays them for a day when their eyes
will look in horror guys like thean said
Allah has a and a Time patience those
people have been patient when they are
going for the suffering so don't you all
of us come and say oh they're going you
know some people come and say oh they're
going through that I don't believe in
God I'm like it's very interesting the
one that's the one that's getting bombs
dropped on them they have they believe
in God more but you sitting at home
having Doritos and watching something
that's a joke a bigger joke than you
yeah thank you for the honesty brother
sisters I hope this was satisfied as
much as it was for us for you guys in
you guys played an amazing role in this
and it continues the of thean lians we
ask Allah that all he allows us to see
before we die may Allah bless Ander you
guys being a part of this amazing
project and and carrying on in May Allah
bless you guys till next time from Italy
with the Salah plus project we brought
to Italy across Europe andan is a St
supporter of this may Allah bless and
preserve you guys next time that's what
you think you're doing but you don't
understand the impact you're doing so
next
time shut your mouth shut your mouth
shut you shut your mou Sor you want to
punch in your face uh maybe later